the pandemic has affected everyone how
did it impact you and have you done
anything special during this pandemic
new hobbies did you read study right
what have you done
one of the good things was that i
got to spend more time with my with my
family so i have a six-year-old boy and
it was great and normally
i'm
away from home like half half of the
year or something like that yeah i pick
up a lot of new openings i learn a lot
of new stuff and i try
in my online games this break has done
me a lot of good
it's definitely given me some more time
to think about how many careers doing
chess wise
also
during the break and due cancellation
major tournaments last year i was
able to have time to write a book make
some video video courses it was pretty
huge work
something that a lot of people have been
doing already by that point but
something that i only really started
doing seriously in 2020 was streaming
uh which did uh i think a lot of good
for my like general well-being more than
anything else yeah i mean i think there
are many things that have changed for me
in the last 18 months um you know first
and foremost obviously i started
streaming but i think with the lockdown
everything kind of uh sort of escalator
became much bigger online and mainly
there were many people stuck at home and
they were trying to follow chess or
whatever their interests were
fortunately for me there were still many
online events that i could play and keep
myself busy
to train and prepare for those so i
would say that it didn't really change
my lifestyle too much to be honest it
was not easy for me last one year i have
some health problems also and for this
reason
doctors say no sports no
no activity i mean i
played
just
well i made an entire uh opening
repertoire uncheckable which took a lot
of work i just like published a full-on
opening repertoire based on playing g4
for white and playing the classical
sicilian the semi-slot for black so that
took a lot of work i've always been very
serious about dieting and physical
fitness but it's hard to maintain the
same level when you're traveling like
crazy you're constantly getting on
planes and you're in jet lag so i really
doubled down on that and got back into
the same kind of physical shape that i
was when i was like 20. i might have
picked up some weight you know
i was pretty much staying at home and i
had a very nice time with my wife and
i was it was really i mean for me it
sounds pretty sad but for me it was one
of the best periods because you know i
had no
like you know this regular stress that
comes with playing a professional chess
i was just at home enjoying a
merry life and generally things that i
usually enjoy just i had much more time
for them
except at some point i was really bored
in the winter and i
tried to learn the rubik's cube
and i learned that and now i'm pretty
sure i've forgotten it